This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is part 3 of the 2020-2021 mini-story episodes, where I interview the staff about their favorite little stories from the bill world that don't quite fill out an entire episode for whatever reason, but are great at 99 PI stories nonetheless. We have music games with Sean Raeow, lost statues with Joe Rosenberg and overactive heaters with Delaney Hall. Stay with us. Hey D, what do you have for us today? So today I want to talk with you about old radiators and have you ever lived with an old radiator? I have. Where we met, like, I don't know, 15 years ago in Chicago, when we worked together at the
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是2020-2021年迷你故事集的第三部分。在这期节目中，我采访了我们的工作人员，听他们讲述他们最喜欢的、关于建筑世界的精彩小故事。这些故事无论出于什么原因，都不足以撑起整整一期节目，但作为“99%隐形”的故事依然非常棒。我们有肖恩·雷奥带来的音乐游戏，乔·罗森伯格带来的失踪雕像，以及德莱尼·霍尔带来的过热暖气。请继续收听。嗨，D，你今天给我们带来了什么？是这样的，今天我想和你聊聊老式散热器，你以前住处有用过老式散热器吗？用过。我们大约15年前在芝加哥相遇的时候，当时我们一起在当地的
station there, I lived in at least one apartment that had a radiator, which was, yeah, it was a confounding device. Yeah, I mean, they are notorious for being loud, you know, like clanking a lot. loud, you know, like clanking a lot. And also just for being too hot. Yeah, blisteringly hot. Right, right. So I don't know if you've ever wondered why that is. But I recently, I recently learned that there is a reason for it. And it's actually related not to this current pandemic we're all living through, but to the flu pandemic of 1918 and 1919. Well, I've heard a little bit about this, but I don't know the full story, so I'm excited that you're bringing this to us. Yeah, yeah.
那个电台工作，我住过至少一间有散热器的公寓，那真是个让人摸不透的装置。对，我的意思是，它们出了名的吵，你知道的，比如会发出很多当啷当啷的噪音。吵，你知道的，比如会发出很多当啷当啷的噪音。而且还总是太热。对，热得烫人。没错，没错。所以，我不知道你有没有想过这是为什么。但我最近，我最近了解到这背后是有原因的。而且它其实并不是跟我们现在正经历的大流行病有关，而是跟1918年到1919年的流感大流行有关。嗯，我听说过一点这方面的事情，但不知道完整的故事，所以我很高兴你能把这个带给我们。对，对。
So, first of all, I learned about this history in an article in Bloomberg City Lab. It was reported by Patrick Sisson. And it was kind of through that article that I found, Dan Hallahan. So he grew up in the heating industry. His dad worked for this plumbing and heating wholesale are in Manhattan. And now his family runs a website called HeadingHelp.com. He wrote a book called The Lost Art of Steam Heat.
所以，首先，我是从彭博城市实验室（Bloomberg City Lab）的一篇文章中了解到这段历史的。这篇文章是帕特里克·西森报道的。差不多也是通过那篇文章，我找到了丹·霍拉汉。他是伴随着供暖行业长大的。他父亲在曼哈顿的一家管道和供暖批发商工作。现在他的家人经营着一个叫HeatingHelp.com的网站。他还写了一本书，书名叫《蒸汽供暖的失落艺术》。
I mean, basically he's just really into heating, specifically steam heating. It throws such a lovely radiant glow on you. It's like being on the beach. And it's just a wonderful way to heat. And the dogs are always sleeping in front of it. And the cattle pop up on top of it. People will dry their hats and gloves on top of it. It's just a, feels like home.
我的意思是，基本上他就是真的很迷供暖，特别是蒸汽供暖。它能散发出一种非常迷人的辐射热，就像在海滩上一样。这真是一种极好的取暖方式。狗狗总是睡在它前面。猫咪也会跳到它上面。人们会在它上面烘干帽子和手套。这真的让人，感觉就像在家一样。
So he can go on and on waxing poetically about steamy for a long time. I love it. And he got, he got really interested in the history of steam heating in the US. And he said that as he started doing this research, he was looking at these primary source documents, like these old technical manuals. And he kept coming across references to the fresh air movement. I'm on board with the fresh air movement. I'd follow Terry Gross into the gates of hell. I think we're all part of the fresh air movement. Yes. But this is a different
所以他可以滔滔不绝、充满诗意地谈论蒸汽供暖很长时间。我太喜欢了。而且他变得，他对美国蒸汽供暖的历史产生了浓厚的兴趣。他说，当他开始做这项研究时，他在查阅这些原始资料文献，比如那些旧的技术手册。他不断看到对“新鲜空气运动”的引用。我支持新鲜空气运动。我愿意跟着特里·格罗斯走进地狱之门。我想我们都是新鲜空气运动的一部分。是的。但这是一个不同于
fresh air movement. Well, that's too bad. Well, to work on the other one. This one, not with Terry Gross, was a health crusade. It started right after the Civil War. And proponents of the fresh air movement basically thought that stale, uncirculated air was bad, like very bad for your health. They called it vitiated air, which means spoiled air. And they thought that spoiled air was everywhere. Like we were just steeping in it.
新鲜空气运动的项目。好吧，那太遗憾了。好吧，去研究另一个吧。这个不是和特里·格罗斯有关的项目，而是一场健康运动。它始于南北战争刚结束时。新鲜空气运动的支持者基本上认为，陈旧、不流通的空气是不好的，对健康非常非常不好。他们称之为“变质空气”，意思是腐败的空气。他们认为这种腐败的空气无处不在。就像我们整个人都浸泡在其中一样。
People didn't bathe regularly. There was an unventilated stove that would be in the place. So they just said it's dirty air, and it's coming off your body, and it's coming out of your mouth, and you're smoking, and all these things are going on in a sealed apartment that doesn't have good circulation to begin with. So that caught everybody's attention because it wasn't the killing people. And so this was pre-jermeterry, right?
人们不经常洗澡。房间里会有一个不通风的火炉。所以他们只是说这是脏空气，它从你的身体里散发出来，从你的嘴里吐出来，你在抽烟，所有这些事情都发生在一个本来通风就不好的密闭公寓里。所以这吸引了所有人的注意，因为这并不是在杀害人们。而且这还是在发现细菌之前，对吧？
Yeah, it was. Yeah. They have a concept, the mechanism of why unventilated air might be making them sick? They didn't really, at this point, they were just sort of starting to realize that something was up. Yeah. at this point, they were just sort of starting to realize that something was up. And one of the main proponents of the Fresh Air Movement was a guy named Lewis Leeds. He had been an inspector for the Union Army Field Hospitals. And he got really interested in this idea of Vitiated Air. He was convinced that something about
是的，确实如此。他们对为什么不通风的空气可能会让人生病有一个概念或作用机制吗？其实并没有，在这个时候，他们只是开始意识到有些不对劲。是的。在这个时候，他们只是开始意识到有些不对劲。新鲜空气运动的主要支持者之一是一个叫刘易斯·利兹的人。他曾是联邦军队野战医院的检查员。他对“变质空气”这个概念产生了浓厚的兴趣。他确信某种程度上
it was making people ill. And he actually teamed up with Harriet Beecher Stowe, who wrote Uncle Tom's cabin. Yeah, and they created this traveling road show. They would basically go across the country and give lectures with these magic lantern type slides. She got like mom and dad sitting in the parlor and in crows the baby in a long gown and the baby the baby spun it and the baby crows into these vapors that are coming out of the man and they're done in reds so you see comes out of his mouth and it goes to the floor and
正是这个原因让人们生病。他实际上与写过《汤姆叔叔的小屋》的哈里特·比彻·斯托合作了。是的，他们创造了一个巡回演出。他们基本上走遍了全国，用这些幻灯机类型的幻灯片进行演讲。她让爸爸妈妈坐在客厅里，然后一个穿着长袍的婴儿呀呀学语地出场了，婴儿，婴儿转了转，婴儿对着那些从男人身上散发出来的蒸汽呀呀学语，这些蒸汽是用红色画出来的，所以你能看到它从他的嘴里出来，然后落到地板上，
the baby crows into this cloud and the next slide the baby just kind of topples over and dies. Wow that's an extreme form of scared straight. Yeah. As you can imagine, it was pretty effective. They really caught the attention of lots of people. And I was really struck by when Dan was describing these lantern slides that they would show, it really actually reminded me of the coronavirus diagrams you'll see where there's like two people talking to each other and they're sort of spuing red and blue virus droplets all over each other. Yeah, yeah, no that that's scarred me. That in the 90s reports from like 2020, they which are the black lights on hotel rooms of all the organic splatter all over hotel room. I'm scarred for life for that.
婴儿对着这团雾气呀呀学语，而在下一张幻灯片里，婴儿就直接倒下死去了。哇，这是一种极端形式的恐惧警示教育。是的。正如你所能想象的那样，这相当有效。他们确实吸引了大量人们的注意。而且让我印象深刻的是，当丹描述他们展示的这些幻灯片时，实际上真的让我想到了你有时会看到的新冠病毒图解，图里有两个人互相说话，然后他们彼此喷射出红色和蓝色的病毒飞沫。对，对，不，那个真的吓到我了。还有90年代关于2020年左右的报道，它们会在酒店房间里使用黑光灯，照出酒店房间里到处都是有机喷溅物。我为此留下了一辈子的心理阴影。
So these were sort of like the 19th century version of that. And they were part of what helped the fresh air movement really take hold. So it gets very popular. And it gets so popular that building designers actually started adapting their buildings to bring in more fresh air. The tenements suddenly, you know, as they come into their own, have to have their shafts and you have to have more windows and you can't have these hobbles.
所以这些有点像是19世纪版本的这种宣传。它们是帮助新鲜空气运动真正站稳脚跟的一部分。因此它变得非常受欢迎。它变得如此受欢迎，以至于建筑设计师实际上开始改造他们的建筑以引入更多的新鲜空气。随着经济适用公寓的兴起，它们突然必须有通风井，必须有更多的窗户，而且不能再有那种棚屋了。
You know, like you see in the gangs in New York, that sort of thing. So things got better, but then, you know, it took a crisis like this managed flu to really kick it into high gear. What's going on is around this time, and the 19 teens, there are these two things that are happening concurrently.
你知道的，就像你在纽约帮派电影里看到的那样，诸如此类。所以情况有所改善，但是后来，你知道的，需要像这场流感大流行这样的危机才能真正让它进入全速运转状态。当时的情况是，在大约1910年代，有两件事是同时发生的。
And one is the flu pandemic, which, of course, was a devastating global pandemic that was killing hundreds of thousands of people. And then, at the same time, steam heating is really getting going. So steam heating systems are being installed in buildings across the country. And health officials at the time were starting
一个是流感大流行，这当然是一场毁灭性的全球大流行，夺去了数十万人的生命。然后，与此同时，蒸汽供暖真正兴起。因此，全国各地的建筑物都在安装蒸汽供暖系统。当时的卫生官员开始
to push this idea that people needed to keep their windows open even in the winter. And they needed to do that to increase ventilation and minimize flu spread. And if people were going to be keeping their windows open through the winter, they needed like some pretty oversized radiators. And they was saying that because of the first year movement, we have to start designing systems big enough that they can heat the building on the coldest day of the year with the wind blowing and the windows on. Okay, so this is what radiators like even today can be so overpowering because they need to be that hot for the windows to be open.
推行这样一个观点：人们需要保持窗户打开，即使在冬天也是如此。他们需要这样做来增加通风并最大限度地减少流感传播。如果人们要在整个冬天都开着窗户，他们就需要一些相当超大号的散热器。他们说，因为新鲜空气运动，我们必须开始设计足够大的系统，以便它们能够在一年中最冷的日子里、在风刮着且窗户开着的情况下为建筑物供暖。好吧，这就是为什么即使在今天，散热器有时也会让人觉得热得难以忍受，因为它们必须足够热，以防窗户开着。
Yeah, yeah, exactly. And many of those radiator systems were so sturdy and so well built that they are still in use today. Yeah, the one that was in my apartment was certainly put into the 1920s. Yeah. And the kind of interesting thing is that once the pandemic was over, people began to wonder, why do we have the windows open,
是的，是的，完全正确。而且其中许多散热器系统非常坚固、制造精良，以至于今天仍在使用。是的，我公寓里的那个肯定是在20世纪20年代安装的。是的。有趣的是，一旦大流行结束，人们开始纳闷，我们为什么要把窗户打开？
oh that was because of the flu but that's that's gone you know more than 10 years, close the window so they close the window and now they're stifling because it's so hot, ask anybody those who have been having an apartment you know now it is. And so all of those you know stifling people started insisting that something be done about this stifling people started insisting that something be done about this. And what ended up happening is that basically a whole industry arose to retrofit those big overpowering radiators. So companies began to develop the radiator covers. And other people would paint their radiators with this special paint. But if you use something called a bronzing paint, specifically an aluminum bronzing paint, which has flakes of metal in it,
哦，那是为了流感，但那个已经过去了，你知道的，都过去10多年了，把窗户关上吧。于是他们关上了窗户，结果现在热得透不过气来，因为天气太热了。随便问问那些住过那种公寓的人，你知道现在就是这样。于是，所有那些透不过气来的人开始坚持要求采取措施解决这种闷热状况。最后发生的情况是，基本上涌现出了整个行业来改造那些又大又过猛的散热器。因此，各大公司开始研发散热器罩。还有其他人会用这种特殊的涂料来刷他们的散热器。但是，如果你使用一种叫做古铜色涂料的东西，特别是铝制古铜色涂料，里面含有金属薄片，
that will reduce the radiators ability to radiate by 20%. So just by painting the radiators silver with this special paint, you're downsizing it. And this is why radiators are all silver for the most part. Wow, I knew the idea that was why they were silver. I mean, they were very often so far. Yeah, yeah, they are. It also must be made worse by the fact that the building around it is becoming more
这会使散热器的散热能力降低20%。所以只要用这种特殊的涂料把散热器刷成银色，你就在变相减小它的功率。这就是为什么散热器基本上都是银色的。哇，我以前知道这就是它们为什么是银色的原因。我的意思是，它们经常是银色的。是的，是的，确实如此。周围的建筑变得越来越
thermally efficient. Like buildings, you know, trap more heat in than they used to, and that must make it even worse. Yeah. Yeah. Compared to, you know, the 19 teens buildings now are basically like hermetically sealed. In some office buildings, you cannot open the windows. It's not designed that way.
节能，这肯定也让情况变得更糟。就像建筑物比过去更能锁住热量，这一定让情况变得更糟糕。是的。是的。与1910年代相比，现在的建筑物基本上就像是密封的。在一些办公楼里，你根本打不开窗户。它们的设计就不是那样的。
It's not an option. And so, as you can imagine, that has become an issue with our current pandemic. You need a lot of air coming in. You need a lot of air coming in. You need fresh air. So and many of these high-end modern buildings can't do that. And then Windows don't open. So this is where we're faced right now. What do we do with that? I have been wondering if this current pandemic would shift us back a little bit more towards open-air buildings because the need for fresh air and space
这不是一个选项。因此，你可以想象，这在我们当前的大流行中已经成了一个问题。你需要大量的空气进来。你需要大量的空气进来。你需要新鲜空气。所以，许多这些高端的现代建筑做不到这一点。而且窗户打不开。所以这就是我们目前面临的困境。我们该怎么办？我一直在想，当前的大流行是否会让我们稍微回归一点露天建筑，因为对新鲜空气和空间的需求
seems as necessary as it was in the 19 teens. Right, yeah. I think there's two forces kind of pulling in opposite directions. One is that knowledge that we have now very vividly that buildings need to be ventilated. And then also this continuing pressure to make the more energy efficient because of climate change.
似乎和1910年代一样必要。对，是的。我认为有两股力量在朝相反的方向拉扯。一股是我们现在非常生动地认识到的建筑需要通风的知识；另一股是由于气候变化，继续施加压力使其更加节能。
So it'll be interesting to watch what happens. Yeah. I mean, one of the things that struck me as we were doing a bunch of episodes in the beginning of the pandemic and the lockdown is how many things that we're trying today to slow this pandemic down, like masks and quarantine and open windows, they're so old. They were the same techniques that were, they were people were doing a hundred years ago. I know, I know, I know, it sort of feels like the vaccine, that is this, you is this monumental achievement of modern science. Yeah, especially these vaccines.
所以看着事情会如何发展将会很有趣。我的意思是，当我们在大流行和封锁初期制作了一堆节目时，让我震惊的一件事是，今天为了减缓这场大流行我们正在尝试的许多方法，比如口罩、隔离和开窗，它们是如此古老。它们和人们在一百年前使用的技术完全一样。我知道，我知道，我知道，这感觉有点像疫苗，这是现代科学的一项不朽成就。是的，尤其是这些疫苗。
Yeah, these vaccines, but everything else we're working with is like a really old technology. Just like stay away from each other, cover your faces, open the windows. That's what we've got. That was senior Producer Delaney Hall. To read Patrick's Sissence Full Story of STEAM heating and its connection to the history of the 1918 Flu Pandemic,
是的，这些疫苗，但我们正在使用的其他一切都像是一项非常古老的技术。就像彼此保持距离、遮住脸、打开窗户。这就是我们所拥有的全部。以上是资深制作人德莱尼·霍尔。要阅读帕特里克·西森关于蒸汽供暖及其与1918年流感大流行历史的联系的完整故事，
visit Bloomberg City Lab and to learn more about Dan Hollahan, visit heatinghelp.com. help.com. All right. So I'm here with producer Joe Rosenberg. Hey, Roman. How's it going? I'm good. I'm good.
请访问彭博城市实验室（Bloomberg City Lab）；要了解更多关于丹·霍拉汉的信息，请访问heatinghelp.com。好了。那么我和制作人乔·罗森伯格在一起。嗨，罗曼。最近怎么样？我很好，我很好。
So what is the many that you have for us today? Well, so what I've got for you here is a kind of mini sequel. Okay. Because if you passed your memory back, not actually too all that long ago, you will recall 99PI produced a story about monuments to Lenin. Right, right. Julia Barton to this right for us. It's kind of about what happened to all those Lenin monuments in Eastern Europe after the collapse of the Soviet Union in 91. As our listeners probably know, and probably know, even if they didn't hear that episode, after the Soviet Union collapsed, a great many of those statues of Lenin, busts of Lenin,
所以你今天给我们带来了什么迷你节目？嗯，所以我这里为你准备的是一个类似迷你续集的内容。好的。因为如果你把记忆回溯到其实并不算太久远的时候，你会记起99PI制作过一个关于列宁纪念碑的故事。没错，没错。朱莉娅·巴顿为我们写了这篇稿子。它大致讲的是苏联在91年解体后，东欧所有那些列宁纪念碑都发生了什么。正如我们的听众可能知道的，而且即使没有听过那一期节目也可能知道，苏联解体后，大量的列宁雕像、列宁半身像，
and really all sorts of monuments to Lenin were toppled. They were torn down or pulverized or even like... Stammatically. Yeah. tossed into the black sea and consigned to various other sad fates. Yeah. And I think what the story was centered on, and what was interesting to me is that there are some still standing in Russia that the ones that weren't destroyed,
以及各种各样的列宁纪念碑都被推倒了。它们被拆毁、粉碎，甚至像……系统性地。是的。扔进黑海，并迎来了其他各种悲惨的命运。是的。我认为这个故事的中心，也是让我感兴趣的是，俄罗斯仍然矗立着一些纪念碑，那些没有被摧毁的纪念碑，
that were put in these Soviet nostalgia parks alongside statues of other former communist leaders. It was a way of dealing with this history without completely destroying it. Yeah, exactly. They kind of almost like bracketed it off. They just kind of met a frame around it. And so everyone was able to look at it and you could just project what you wanted onto
它们被安置在这些苏联怀旧公园里，与其它前共产主义领导人的雕像摆在一起。这是一种处理这段历史而不将其完全摧毁的方式。是的，exactly。它们差不多就像是被加了括号隔开。它们只是给它加上了一个框架。于是每个人都能够看着它，你可以在这个相对安全的空间里把你想投射的东西投射到
it in this kind of safer space or something. That is the main thing that most people know about these old Lenin monuments, which is that most of them are gone or defunct in one way or another. But I am here to tell you that there is one monument to Lenin that not only lives on, but I think it's safe to say it will not be toppled anytime soon. It is arguably, arguably the most secure Lenin in the world.
它上面，诸如此类。这是大多数人对这些旧列宁纪念碑的主要印象，那就是它们大多数都以这样或那样的方式消失了或不复存在了。但我今天要告诉你的是，有一个列宁纪念碑不仅长存至今，而且我认为可以肯定地说，它在短期内绝不会被推倒。它可以说是，可以说是世界上最安全的列宁雕像。
Okay. So why is that? Why is this one survived? And we'll probably survive amongst all the others that have been toppled. Well to answer that, first of all, let me ask you, have you ever heard of something called a pull of inaccessibility? No, I haven't. It sounds a little ominous.
好的。那是为什么？为什么这个能在所有其他被推倒的纪念碑中幸存下来？为了回答这个问题，首先，让我问你，你听说过所谓的不访问极吗？不，我没听过。听起来有点不吉利。
What is the pull of inaccessibility? So a pull of inaccessibility, it's both ominous and not. It is the geographical term that indicates the location on a given landmass that is further from the coastline than any other spot on that landmass. So every continent and every island has its own pole of inaccessibility or POI. So for example, North America's POI
什么是不访问极？所以，不访问极，它既不吉利也不是那么回事。这是一个地理术语，指特定陆地上距离海岸线比该陆地上任何其他地点都要远的位置。因此，每个大陆和每个岛屿都有其自己的不访问极或POI。例如，北南美洲的不访问极
is on the Pine Ridge Reservation in South Dakota. It's 1,030 miles from the nearest coastline. Asia has a POI in the desert of Western China. It's about 1,500 miles from the coast. But even something like the island of Great Britain has its own pole of inaccessibility. According to the British Ordnance Survey, it is near church flat farm in the county of Derbyshire
位于南达科他州的派恩里奇印第安人保留地。它距离最近的海岸线有1030英里。亚洲的不访问极在中国西部的沙漠中。它距离海岸大约1500英里。甚至连大不列颠岛这样的小地方也有它自己的不访问极。根据英国军械测量局的数据，它位于德比郡的科奇平原农场附近，
and is a mere 70 miles from the coast. It's not that inaccessible. No, I think you could knock that one out pretty easily if you wanted to. But anyway, the reason I bring this all up is because way back in 1958, a team of scientists from the Soviet Union became the first people to ever reach the southern pole of inaccessibility. And so this is the POI for Antarctica. Is it actually the South Pole or not?
距离海岸仅70英里。那并没有那么难以访问。不，我想如果你想的话，你可以很轻松地把它拿下。不管怎样，我提起这一切的原因是，早在1958年，一个来自苏联的科学家团队成为第一批到达南方不访问极的人。所以这是南极洲的不访问极。它其实就是南极点吗，还是不是？
No. So the South Pole is closer to the coast because if you think about it, like there's that like big chunk taken out of like one side of Antarctica. It's a little lopsided, right? It's got that chunk taken out of it. And so the South Pole is actually much closer to that coastline than the pole of inaccessibility, which true to its name for these Russian scientists was really hard to get to. It's like really inaccessible. Oh yeah, like it was. So by definition,
不是的。南极点距离海岸更近，因为如果你仔细想想，南极洲的一侧有一个很大的缺口。它有点不对称，对吧？它被挖掉了一个缺口。因此，南极点实际上比不访问极距离海岸线要近得多，而不访问极名副其实，对于这些俄罗斯科学家来说真的很难到达。它确实非常难以接近。哦，是的，就像那样。所以根据定义，
further inland than the geographic South Pole, plus, you know, it's Antarctica. So, you know, it was already also on the higher and colder part of the continent. And then the further you are from the shoreline, the colder it tends to get. So, you know, we met to the South Pole in 1911, but when the Soviets finally got to the Southern Pole of an accessibility, that took them another half century to reach. I mean, I guess it has not, doesn't have a lot of symbolic virtue and it seems like a horrible place. So why would you bother? They weren't really in a rush to get there. And apparently they weren't in a rush to stay there either because once this team of Soviet scientists got there, they tried to set up this
它比地理南极点更深入内陆，而且，你知道的，这里是南极洲。所以，你知道，它已经在该大陆更高更冷的部分了。而且你距离海岸线越远，天气往往就越冷。所以，你知道的，我们在1911年到达了南极点，但当苏联人最终到达南方不访问极时，他们花了另外半个世纪才到达。我的意思是，我猜它没有什么象征价值，而且看起来是个可怕的地方。那为什么要费劲去呢？他们其实并不急于去那里。显然他们也不急于呆在那里，因为一旦这个苏联科学家团队到达那里，他们试图建立这个
meteorological research station, but it was like insanely cold. The average temperature was something like negative 72 degrees Fahrenheit. Average. Oh my God. Yeah. That's horrible. So right. So like just after like 12 days, they were like screw this. And they left. Yeah, smart. Good call. Yeah. Excellent call. But before they return to civilization, they left behind a bust of Lenin. Of course. It's just the Soviet thing to do. And so here, let me show you a photo of what it looked like. Wow, there it is. There's Lenin, a bust of Lenin, right on the top of,
气象研究站，但那里冷得发疯。平均气温大约是零下72华氏度。平均气温。天哪。是的。太可怕了。所以，是的。就在短短12天后，他们就觉得去他的吧。然后他们就离开了。是的，明智。好决定。是的，极其明智的决定。但在他们重返文明世界之前，他们留下了一尊列宁半身像。当然。这很符合苏联的作风。所以，来，我给你看一张它当时样子的照片。哇，它就在那儿。那是列宁，一个列宁半身像，就在……
a kind of like a pedestal of some kind. What is that? So that is actually the chimney of the research station, and which they dragged all the way there, like a pedestal of some kind, what is that? So that is actually the chimney of the research station and which they've dragged all the way there, thinking probably that they'd use it for longer than 12 days. But now it serves this function of making sure Lenin is as lofty and dignified as possible as he gazes out over the white expanse.
某种基座的顶端。那是什么？那其实是研究站的烟囱，他们把它一路拖到了那里，就像某种基座一样，那是什么？那其实是研究站的烟囱，他们把它一路拖到了那里，心想他们可能会使用它超过12天。但现在它的功能是确保列宁尽可能崇高、有尊严地凝视着白色的开阔地。
I mean, despite this start surrounding, so I mean, this look like just a classic Lenin bust, like generic Lenin bust. Oh, yeah, totally the furrowed brow, the jutting chin. It's almost like at the last second before they left, they just grabbed a spare Lenin off the shelf and just kind of took it with them. So I confess, yeah, it's not much to look at,
我的意思是，尽管周围环境如此，所以我的意思是，这看起来就像一个经典的列宁半身像，就像普通的列宁半身像。哦，是的，完全是紧锁的眉头，突出的下巴。这几乎就像在他们离开前的最后一秒，他们只是从架子上抓了一个备用的列宁，然后顺便带走了。所以我承认，是的，这没什么好看的，
but I kind of think of it as like the gargoyle on the top of a cathedral, because like after they left, it was never intended to be seen by anyone. Right, like the gargoyle has a function, but the people on the ground can't see gargoyles. They're meant for the designer of the church and maybe for God and that's it.
但我有点把它看作是大教堂顶上的石像鬼，因为就像他们离开后，它从来没打算被任何人看到。没错，就像石像鬼有功能，但地面上的人看不到石像鬼。它们是为教堂的设计者准备的，也许是为上帝准备的，仅此而已。
Right, exactly. Or in the case of this Lenin, pleasing to the materialist, forces him, Marxist, the Leninism. It sounds like I'm joking, but they even oriented it so that it would forever face towards Moscow. So are these pictures you're showing me from when it was erected or did people come afterward to check it out? How inaccessible is the land
对，没错。或者在这个列宁的例子中，取悦唯物主义力量，他，马克思列宁主义。听起来像是在开玩笑，但他们甚至调整了它的方向，使其永远面向莫斯科。那么，这些你展示给我的照片是它刚竖起时的，还是后来有人去查看过？这块土地有多难接近
at the pole of inaccessibility? He's pretty inaccessible. These photos are the originals. There was a brief spurt of visits by pole of inaccessibility standards in the 1960s. The Soviets went back super briefly in 64, then in 65 an American research team dropped by, climbed up the pedestal
在不访问极？它相当难以接近。这些照片是原件。在20世纪60年代，按照不访问极的标准，曾有过一小阵访问热潮。苏联人在64年极短暂地回去过，然后在65年，一个美国研究团队顺道拜访，爬上了基座，
and swiveled the bust so that Lenin faced towards Washington DC. At which point, learning of the American antics, the Soviets came back down one last time and swiveled him back towards Moscow. I mean, this is an aspect of the Cold War that I can totally get behind. Oh, yeah, I mean, if the whole Cold War was just like somehow like dueling pranks for the sake of like national pride, that would be
并旋转了半身像，让列宁面向华盛顿特区。在那个时候，得知美国人的恶作剧后，苏联人最后一次返回，并把他转回面向莫斯科。我的意思是，这是冷战的一个方面，我完全可以接受。哦，是的，我的意思是，如果整个冷战只是一场为了国家荣誉而互相恶作剧的比赛，那会
a much better. After that little back and forth, after that little duel, for many, many decades, there was nothing. The Southern POI went kind of forgotten and unvisited, which means that all through the rest of the Cold War and Paris-Stroica and the fall of the Berlin Wall and the collapse of the Soviet Union, as all the other statues and busts of Lenin were being toppled all over the world. This one lonely Lenin just sat there untouched by the forces of history. So it wasn't toppled by people marking the fate of planning on the P.O.I.
好得多。在那次小小的来回较量、那次小小的决斗之后，漫长的几十年里，什么也没有发生。南方的POI被渐渐遗忘，无人造访，这意味着在冷战的其余时间、改革开放以及柏林墙倒塌和苏联解体期间，当世界各地其他所有的列宁雕像和半身像都被推倒时，这个孤独的列宁只是静静地坐在那里，没有受到历史力量的触及。所以它并没有被那些在POI上纪念列宁命运的人推倒。
So this is where the story takes a turn because when people finally returned to the area in the mid 2000s, the official position of the P.O.I. Had actually changed in the intervening years due to like updated calculations. So the new focus was on being the first to go to these new coordinates and nav that record. And checking up on Lenin to see if he was still kicking just it just wasn't a priority. But nevertheless, there was at least one person who continued to believe that Lenin was still there at the old P.O.I. and could be found. There's no way I was ending on the Let Good. So one way or other, I was crawling to the pole of an accessibility. I was always going that.
所以这就是故事发生转折的地方，因为当人们在2000年代中期最终重返该地区时，由于更新的计算，POI的官方位置在这些年里实际上已经改变了。因此新的焦点是成为第一个去往这些新坐标并创下纪录的人。而查看列宁是否还在运转只是……这并不是首要任务。然而，至少有一个人仍然相信列宁仍然在旧的POI并且可以被找到。我绝不可能以“好吧”来结束。所以不管怎样，我都要爬到不访问极去。我一直都打算去那儿。
So who is that? So that is Henry Cooxon. And today he runs an adventure travel outfit called Cooxon Adventures. But back in 2006, he was not a professional adventure. He was just kind of a random dude who along with two other friends, Rupert Longsden and Roy Sweet, just kind of got obsessed with finding this bust of Lenin at the southern pole of an accessibility. Oh yeah, none of us had a clue. I had my two. We didn't know where the North South, we didn't
那么那是谁？那个人是亨利·库克森。如今他经营着一家名为“库克森探险”的探险旅游公司。但在2006年，他还不是一个职业探险家。他只是一个普通的家伙，和另外两个朋友鲁珀特·朗斯登和罗伊·斯威特一起，有点痴迷于在南方不访问极找到这个列宁半身像。哦，是的，我们谁也没有头绪。我有两个……我们不知道北南在哪里，我们不知道
know where the penguins were North or South. We didn't know the polar bears we knew nothing about these areas. Please, I was like the right man for the job. Yeah, but I actually do firmly believe in beginner's luck. Like you don't know, you're not supposed to do certain things. So you just do them and then you kind of get away with them. Everyone else they consulted with basically said, why even bother at this point? Because even if you get there, you're not going to find anything.
企鹅在北边还是南边。我们不知道北极熊，我们对这些地区一无所知。拜托，我就像是做这件工作的不二人选。是的，但我确实坚信初学者有好运。就像你什么都不知道，你不知道自己不该做某些事情。所以你只是去做了，然后你有点侥幸逃脱了惩罚。他们咨询过的其他人基本上都说，到了这个时候为什么还要费心思呢？因为即使你到了那里，你也什么都找不到。
They just looked at us and said, Lenin is going to be buried under the snow. Huge structures have been buried over the decades. So a small little statue that no one's been to in 40, 50 years without doubt it's not going to be that. Oh, wow. So so they could be right on it right there, but Lenin could be so buried they would not actually find it. Correct. So they hired a fourth person, a veteran Antarctic explorer named Paul Landry to help supervise their team. But there was still this complication because even though great
他们看着我们说，列宁会被埋在雪底下。巨大的建筑物在几十年里都被埋了。所以一个小小的、40、50年没人去过的雕像，毫无疑问是找不到的。哦，哇。所以……所以他们可能就在正上方，但列宁可能被埋得太深以至于他们实际上找不到。没错。所以他们雇用了第四个人，一位名叫保罗·兰德里的资深南极探险家来协助监督他们的团队。但仍然存在这样一个复杂情况，因为尽管南极冰盖的很大一部分
parts of the Antarctic ice sheet are you know, calving away due to climate change, the middle of the continent, the snow is still just accumulating and then compacts down into ice. And at the pole of inaccessibility, one of the things that makes it a challenging place to go is that the ice there is, I believe, 13,000 feet deep. But nevertheless, just by the odds, they decided to go look for a linen. And so they went down to Antarctica. They used kites to help pull themselves in their supplies across the ice. That's cool. Yeah, and I will skip over the details of the journey itself.
你知道的，由于气候变化而在崩解，但大陆中部，雪仍在不断累积，然后压实成冰。而在不访问极，使其成为一个具有挑战性的地方的原因之一是那里的冰层据我所知有13,000英尺深。然而，仅凭概率，他们决定去寻找列宁。于是他们去了南极洲。他们用风筝帮助拉着自己和补给穿过冰层。太酷了。是的，我会略过这段旅程本身的细节。
You know, insert your standard extremes of Antarctica statistics here. But I will just say that to reach the suspected location of the Russian station took them 46 days. Holy moly, oh my god. The whole way there was just pure horizon. And almost entirely flat featureless landscape. And after this monotonous journey, they had to contend with the possibility that when they got to the coordinates, Lenin would be so buried in the snow that all they would see was more flat featureless landscape.
你知道的，在这里插入你标准的南极洲极端统计数据。但我只想说，到达俄罗斯站的可疑地点花了他们46天。天哪，我的天啊。一路上只有纯粹的地平线。几乎完全是平坦、毫无特征的地貌。在经历了这段单调的旅程之后，他们不得不面对这样一种可能性：当他们到达坐标时，列宁会被雪埋得如此之深，以至于他们看到的只有更多的平坦、毫无特征的地貌。
We had only seen white, you know, white snow and sky on our own cells and tent for the last 50 odd days. And we reached the said coordinates. We are absolutely exhausted with freezing cold, and we can see nothing. So, you know, we agreed to keep on pushing. And after a few minutes, I see this tiny little black dot on the horizon. A few more minutes, and this little black dot starts to grow into something more substantial, and then suddenly you can make out, you know, the outline of a man. And there was this silence, we put down our kites, and we just walked, we walked in silence up to this statute, and there. And there was there was let it.
我们在过去的50多天里，在自己的雪橇和帐篷里，看到的只有白色的雪和天空。我们到达了所述坐标。我们筋疲力尽，冻得要命，却什么也看不到。所以，你知道的，我们同意继续前进。几分钟后，我在地平线上看到了一个小小的黑色小点。又过了几分钟，这个小小的黑色小点开始长成更实质性的东西，然后突然你能辨认出，你知道的，一个人的轮廓。四周一片寂静，我们放下了风筝，我们只是走着，默默地走向这座雕像，然后就在那里。而在那里，列宁就在那儿。
Wow, I cannot believe they found them. They did. He wasn't buried under the snow, at least not yet. And I have to say, I just love this part of the story because here's a photo of what Lenin looked like when they did find him. Wow. So it's really just the top of the chimney
哇，我简直不敢相信他们找到了。他们真的找到了。他没有被埋在雪下，至少还没完全埋进去。我必须说，我真的很喜欢故事的这一部分，因为这里有一张当他们找到列宁时他样子的照片。哇。所以真的只剩下烟囱顶部
that's left and the bust. I mean, that he's just barely hanging on. It's been reduced to a kind of, I don't know, what do you call it, like a plinth? I don't know. Yeah. To give you a sense of scale, the snow had been accumulating obviously
和半身像了。我的意思是，他简直是命悬一线。他已经被缩小到了一种，我不知道，你怎么称呼它，就像一个柱基？我不知道。是的。为了让你对比例有个概念，显然在过去的48年里雪一直在堆积，
in the previous 48 years, but it hadn't quite made it all the way up. The original chimney of the Russian station was maybe let's say 30 feet high, and now only about six to seven feet were left. Making the Lenin at that pole of inaccessibility a tad more accessible. Yeah, you can reach up and touch it, yeah. Which is exactly what they did. The really bizarre thing was, you know, we're expecting this to be a bronze or something, you know, a steel, and it was made of some sort of weird yellow plastic
但还没完全堆积上来。俄罗斯站最初的烟囱大概有30英尺高，现在只剩下大约6到7英尺了。这使得不访问极上的列宁变得更容易接近了一点。是的，你可以伸手去摸到他，是的。而这正是他们所做的。真正离奇的事情是，你知道的，我们期望这是一个青铜或其他材质的，你知道的，钢铁的，而它是某种奇怪的黄色塑料
compound, which is very light. You could you could pick him up. Did you pick him up? We did pick him up, yeah. Did they make him face towards London or something? Yeah, so of course I asked Henry precisely that and he said no. They left him facing towards Moscow, but not before goofing around just a bit. He might have been dressed up a little bit. Nothing too reverent. We put a hat on him and some goggles and pictures of us all, group, hubble around him and everything else. I think he's left with his pride intact. I'm glad they left his pride intact, but it sounds like he's not going to last for that much
复合物制成的，非常轻。你可以……你可以把他拿起来。你们把他拿起来了吗？我们确实把他拿起来了，是的。他们让他面向伦敦还是什么的？是的，所以我当然确切地问了亨利这个问题，他说没有。他们让他保持面向莫斯科，但在那之前稍微胡闹了一下。他可能被稍微打扮了一下。没什么太大不敬。我们给他戴了一顶帽子，戴上了一些护 goggles（护目镜），拍了我们所有人的照片，大家聚在他周围合影等等。我想他保住了尊严。我很高兴他们保留了他的尊严，但听起来他撑不了多久了，
longer because if the ice has accumulated around 20 feet in the 50 years and there's only about six feet left. It seems like Lenin will be gone in another decade or so. Could you remind me when his expedition was? Yeah, so Henry's expedition was December of 2006 is when they started. They found Lenin in January of 2007. So it's already like, you know, 13, 14 years. And so do people know if Lenin is still there? Is it almost up for Lenin? So of course, that's the big question, right? And as it turns out, the Russian station has been visited at least two more times since then. And of course, each set of visitors took the obligatory photo posing next to Lenin.
因为如果在50年里冰已经堆积了大约20英尺，而现在只剩下大约六英尺。看起来列宁在另一个十年左右就会消失。你能提醒我他的探险是什么时候吗？是的，所以亨利的探险是在2006年12月开始的。他们在2007年1月找到了列宁。所以这已经有，你知道的，13、14年了。那么人们知道列宁是否还在那里吗？列宁快要撑不住了吗？所以，当然，这是个大问题，对吧？事实证明，自那以后，俄罗斯站至少又被访问了两次。当然，每一批游客都在列宁旁边摆姿势拍了必不可少的照片。
So here's a photo of an Norwegian team that got there just one year later in 2008. Oh, so yeah, he's already lost a foot at least, you know, maybe maybe two or three feet. The bottom of the top of the plinth right where the bus starts is just about chest height on most of these guys. I'd say it shaved off. Let's go with a foot. I think a foot. Okay. But even more recent data, much more recent data, is from this photo taken by a solo Australian
所以这是一张挪威团队的照片，他们在仅仅一年后的2008年到达了那里。哦，所以是的，他至少已经失去了一英尺，你知道的，也许是两到三英尺。柱基顶部的底部，也就是半身像开始的地方，对这些家伙来说大约在胸口高度。我想它被削掉了一截。算一英尺吧。我觉得有一英尺。好吧。但更新的数据，更新得多的数据，来自一名澳大利亚单人探险家拍摄的照片，他去过，基本上你昨天刚去过。这张照片拍摄于2019年12月。这张照片里，看起来离地面大概有两英尺左右。他在这张照片里是坐着的，但如果他站起来，他会比那更高。在他之上。是的。是的。我很高的。是的。是的。不过我要说的是，我确实认为这个乏味的、流水线式的列宁，配上他那标准的、坚定的表情，
adventure who went, basically, you went yesterday. This photo was taken in December of 2019. And this one, it looks like a, like, maybe two foot off the ground. He's sitting in this photo, but if he stood up, he would be taller than that. Above it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. My tall. Yeah. Yeah. I will say, however, that I do, I do think that this like kind of drab cookie cutter Lenin with its standard issue, define expression.
对于这种情况来说是完美的雕像。就像，你知道的，因为他看起来从不担心。就像冰层在侵蚀，他，他似乎只是在说，就像，你知道的，因为他看起来从不担心，就像冰层在侵蚀，放马过来吧。是的，他绝对是以一种令人钦佩的斯多葛主义面对这种命运。但是，但是无论如何他的命运都将降临。我的意思是，如果我来猜测的话，一年大概是一英尺左右，或者两英尺。我的意思是，你说的最多五年他就彻底消失了。有什么想法吗，你知道的，你应该拯救
Is the perfect statue for this situation? Like, you know, because like he never looks worried. Like even as the ice encroaches, he, he seems to just be saying, like, you know, because like he never looks worried, like even as the ice encroaches, he seems to just be saying, like, you know, bring it on. Yeah, he's definitely is facing this fate with a sort of admirable stoicism. But like, but his fate is coming no matter what. I mean, like, if I were to gas or like it, it did about another foot in a, or two feet in a year. I mean, you're talking five years max before he's gone for good. Is there any notion that, you know, you should save
他吗？我的意思是，这只是一个列宁半身像。他们只是拿走他还是你觉得会发生什么？好吧，首先，拿走他将是一项条约违规行为。拿走他。拿走他。是的。南极洲受共同管辖……拿走他。没错。是的。南极洲受《南极条约》签字国的共同管辖。2012年，签字国批准了一份需要保护的历史遗迹和纪念碑名单。
him? I mean, it's just a blast to see bust of Lenin. They just like take him or what do you think will happen? Well, for starters, it would be a treaty violation. To take him. To take him. Yeah. Antarctica is under the joint jurisdiction of take him. That's true. Yeah. Antarctica is under the joint jurisdiction of the signatories of the Antarctic treaty. And in 2012, the signatories approved a list of historic sites and monuments to be preserved.
而且实际上有很多，名单上有86处纪念碑。南极洲有86处纪念碑。让我告诉你，南极洲有惊人数量的牌匾。没人读的牌匾。对，完全正确。但你知道，我想这一次，如果我们的听众没有读过南极洲的牌匾，99 PI可以原谅他们。但排名第四的是南方不访问极的列宁半身像。哦，所以这是需要保护的历史古迹之一？哦，是的，绝对是。如果它在名单上排名第四，真搞笑。你能看到它们。
And there's a lot actually there for like 86 monuments on the list. 86 monuments on Antarctica. Let me just tell you, there's a surprising number of plaques in Antarctica. plaques which no one reads. Right exactly. But you know, I think this time, 99 PI can forgive our listeners if they haven't read the Antarctica plaques. But coming in at number four was the bust of Lenin at the Southern pole of inaccessibility. Oh, so this is one of the historic monuments that has to be preserved? Oh, yeah, absolutely. And if it's number four on the list, it's funny. You can see them.
这个是由丹麦列出的，这个是由美国列出的。我想这是俄罗斯列出的第一个或第二个。就像列宁半身像留在那儿一样。所以如果你试图移动它，普京会派人做掉你。当然。但我个人认为有一个更重要的理由不要移动它，那就是，好吧，实际上，让我从艺术甚至哲学的角度问你，罗曼，你希望看到它被拯救并带回文明世界，还是任其风化？哦，任其风化。不，毫无疑问。它应该被埋葬。这就像艺术项目的一部分
This one is listed by Denmark, and this one is listed by the US. And I think this is either the first or second one listed by Russia. It's like the bust of Lenin stays. So if you tried to move it, Putin would have you killed. Of course. But I personally think there's an even more important reason not to move it, which is, well, actually, let me ask you from an artistic or even philosophical perspective, would you, Roman, want to see it saved and return to civilization or left to the elements. Oh, left to the elements. No, no question. It should be buried. That's like part of the art
据我所知，被埋葬就是其中一部分？是的，我完全同意这一点。使它具有诗意 appeal（吸引力）的整件事在于，他在绝大多数时间里都是不被任何人看到的。他几乎可以通过变得完全无法接近和完全不可见，来达到他柏林纳式的理想状态。你知道，另一个有这种感觉的人是亨利·库克森。他说他曾考虑过把它拿走一小会儿。这是一个非常短暂的想法，想把它放进我们的酒吧然后带回家。所以是的，拿走它的诱惑太大了，把它放进我们的酒吧然后带回家。所以，是的，拿走它的诱惑太大了。但不，我认为他应该留在原来的地方。我想如果你能到达那里，雪已经堆到他脸的一半高左右了，那会很酷。
project. Is it being buried as far as I'm concerned? Yeah, and I have to totally agree with this. The whole thing that makes, it gives it poetic appeal is that he is at least most of the time going unseen by anyone. He almost would like kind of reach his platonic ideal unseen by anyone. He almost would like kind of reach his platonic ideal by being rendered completely inaccessible and completely unseeable. And you know, another person who feels this way is Henry Cooxon. He said he considered taking it for a moment. It was a very fleeting thought of putting him in our pub and bringing him home. So yes, there's a huge temptation to take it, of putting him in our pile, and bringing him home. So yes, yes, there's a huge temptation to take it. But no, I think he should remain where he was put. I think if you could get there and his sort of the snow sort of halfway up his face or something, that would be cool.
项目。就我而言，它是不是被埋没了？是的，我完全同意这一点。整件事情的诗意之处在于，他至少在大多数时候不被任何人看到。他几乎想要通过变得完全无法接近和完全不可见来达到他的柏拉图式理想。你知道，另一个有这种感觉的人是亨利·库克斯逊。他说他曾考虑过一会儿把它拿走。这是一个非常短暂的想法，把他放在我们的酒吧里并带他回家。所以是的，把东西拿走有巨大的诱惑，把他放在我们的堆里，带他回家。所以是的，是的，有巨大的诱惑去拿它。但是不，我认为他应该留在原来的地方。我想如果你能到达那里，雪堆到他脸的一半左右或者别的什么，那会很酷。
Like only his bald head, his slap sticking out before that too is consumed by the snow. Yeah, his final, you know, that finalp, and then he's disappeared into a silent icy grave, you know, that would be poetic. Well, thank you, Joe. This is a really amazing story. I love it. Thank you so much, Roman. This one was a pleasure. I'll play some music games with Sean Rial. We're going to compose a song together after this. All right, so I'm here with our composer, Sean Rial, who has a mini story for us, and
就像只有他的光头，他那挥舞的手掌在被大雪吞没前也露在外面。对，他最后的，你知道，那最后一下，然后他就消失在一个寂静的冰冷坟墓里，你知道，那会很有诗意。好吧，谢谢你，乔。这是一个非常精彩的故事。我很喜欢。非常感谢，罗曼。这期节目非常愉快。我将和肖恩·里尔一起玩一些音乐游戏。之后我们要一起创作一首歌。好的，我和我们的作曲家肖恩·里尔在一起，他为我们准备了一个迷你的故事，并且
you always have a music related mini story for us every year. Mm-hmm. So that's the cases here too. Yep, it is, yeah, very much so. I love talking about music. So what do you have? So today we're going to talk about music games and specifically like music composing games, which is a term, an umbrella term I kind of came up with.
你每年都会为我们准备一个与音乐相关的迷你故事。嗯。所以这次也是这样。是的，确实如此，非常如此。我喜欢谈论音乐。那你有什么？所以今天我们要谈论音乐游戏，特别是像音乐创作游戏，这是我创造的一个术语，一个统称。
I couldn't really find something that really, to really put all these things together, but I swear it feels related. So, okay, so, you know, so these are music games, but not like rhythm games, which I think is what a lot of people think of if you hear the term music game, like rock band or pop it or, you know,
我其实找不到什么词能真正把这些东西组合在一起，但我发誓感觉它们是相关的。所以，你知道的，这些是音乐游戏，但不是那种节奏游戏，我想很多人听到“音乐游戏”这个词时想到的就是那种，比如《摇滚乐队》或《Pop It》，或者，你知道的，
the clapping games that you play on the playground. Right, right. Did you ever play those games, Roman? Rock band for sure. Like I have a rock band set in my house. I still like, I love rock band. Yeah. There's a lot of fun. What about the clapping games? I don't know if I know any clapping games off the top of my head. I know the mainly from, there was this amazing sound recordist and sort of audio anthropologist named Tony Schwartz. He was also an ad man in the in the 60s and he recorded lots of kids games like he was a New Yorker and he basically was a Gora Fobak and he basically stuck to his block. But he recorded all these clapping and kids games that were amazing and there's a
你在操场上玩的拍手游戏。对，对。你玩过那些游戏吗，罗曼？《摇滚乐队》绝对玩过。就像我家买了一套《摇滚乐队》设备。我依然觉得，我超爱《摇滚乐队》。是的。非常有趣。拍手游戏呢？我不知道自己能不能随口说出什么拍手游戏。我主要从一个叫托尼·施瓦茨的了不起的声音录音师兼某种音频人类学家那里了解它们。他在60年代也是个广告人，他录制了大量儿童游戏，因为他是纽约人，基本上有点广场恐惧症，基本上只呆在他自己的街区里。但他录制了所有这些令人惊叹的拍手游戏和儿童游戏，还有一个
Kitchensisters piece about Tony Schwartz, which is like stunning. And one of my favorite pieces of radio. And so I have some different record albums of Tony Schwartz recording clapping kids games and rhyming games and stuff like that. And I think that stuff is really amazing. But I've never done that myself. Yeah, yeah.
关于托尼·施瓦茨的“厨房姐妹”节目，简直太棒了。是我最喜欢的广播节目之一。所以我有一些托尼·施瓦茨录制的拍手儿童游戏、押韵游戏等内容的唱片专辑。我觉得这些东西真的很神奇。但我自己从来没做过。对，对。
I was never really like a clapping game kid at all either. but I also, it's also because I just don't really like rhythm games. Like you would think that maybe that wouldn't be the case in time a musician, but... Yeah, and a drummer most specifically. Yes, but like I just don't, you know, and I think this is why music composing games really appeal to me is because, so what's different about a music composing game is that there are like rules around it, you know, keep it sounding like music or, you know, or like whatever the game determines is music. But the whole idea behind them is that you get something different every single time you play. Okay. You know, and there are lots of different examples of how people
我也从来不是那种玩拍手游戏的小孩。但这也是因为我其实不太喜欢节奏游戏。你可能会觉得作为一个音乐家不该这样……是的，而且最主要是作为一个鼓手。是的，但就是，你知道的，我想这就是为什么音乐创作游戏对我非常有吸引力的原因，因为音乐创作游戏的不同之处在于，它们周围有一些规则，你知道的，要让它听起来像音乐，或者，你知道的，或者不管游戏认定什么是音乐。但它们背后的整个理念是，你每次玩都会得到不同的结果。好吧。你知道的，有许多不同的例子，展示了人们如何
construct ways of basically generating songs and generating different kinds of song experiences from a set of rules. Cool. And some of these examples are a little less maybe historically significant than others, but this is my personal museum we're about to step into. These are my favorites. Okay. Well, let's hear what's the first one? There are like a few games. I kind of feel like they're in the same vein, like kind of through the 1600s, the 1800s. And some of them are done with dice, a composer might like lay out like a certain number of notes or maybe write like a few different like melody variations. And then they kind of like write them on sheets of paper, maybe or like a sign, different melody variations and then they kind of write
构建各种方法，从一组规则中生成歌曲和不同类型的歌曲体验。太棒了。其中有些例子可能在历史上的重要性稍逊一筹，但这是我即将踏入的个人博物馆。这些是我的最爱。好吧，让我们听听第一个是什么？有几个游戏。我总觉得它们属于同一类型，大约从1600年代到1800年代。其中一些是用骰子玩的，作曲家可能会列出一定数量的音符，或者写几个不同的旋律变体。然后他们把它们写在纸上，或者指定不同的旋律变体，然后他们把
a monsheets of paper maybe or an assigned numbers to them and then you roll some dice and then you note it based on what numbers you roll. And so basically you're making a song through chance. You may have even written sections of music, but how one goes into the other and how the song starts ends is like, is all based on just like the chance of the dice. And, you know, it's the kind of thing that you could use maybe as like a writing prompt to like, to, you know, to be like, oh, I'm, I'm totally stuck right now. Well, I'll just like, well, I like these notes. I guess maybe I'll just like see if I can like just like leave it up to God.
这些旋律变体写在纸上或者给它们编上号，然后你掷骰子，根据你掷出的数字来记录。所以基本上你是通过机缘巧合来创作一首歌。你可能甚至写好了音乐的各个部分，但各个部分如何连接，歌曲如何开始和结束，完全取决于骰子的运气。而且，你知道，这种东西你甚至可以把它当作写作提示来用，当你觉得“哦，我现在彻底卡壳了。好吧，我只是，嗯，我挺喜欢这些音符的，我想也许我只是看看能不能完全交给天意吧”。
And I really like that because it sounds like a good way to maybe just like get yourself out of your own way. When you're like, you know, when you're working on something and I, you know, as someone who has like deadlines for music, like I've never tried doing that, but I'm very interested in seeing how that could play out. It seems that the success of this game is contingent upon the little melodies that you assign. They have to be good in themselves and combine well in a random fashion, which is in and of itself its own difficult task. Yeah, you really have to be like a composer already to play a game like this.
我真的很喜欢这个，因为这听起来是个好方法，能让你摆脱自我设限。当你，你知道的，在创作什么东西的时候，而且，你知道的，作为一个有音乐交付期限的人——我从来没试过那样做，但我非常有兴趣看看这会如何发展。看来这个游戏的成功取决于你指定的那些小旋律。它们本身必须足够好，并且能以随机的方式很好地结合在一起，这本身就是一项艰巨的任务。是的，玩这样的游戏，你本身就必须是个作曲家。
Like, you know, it's like you have to have parameters already set, you know, that also like is dependent on like rules you learn based on what you consider to be music. Right. Okay, so next stop in the museum of my favorite music games, Okay, so next stop in the museum of my favorite music games, we've got a little program, computer program called Microsoft Songsmith. Have you ever heard of Microsoft Songsmith? I have not. I mean, it sounds vaguely familiar, but I've never used it. No.
就像，你知道的，你必须已经设定好参数，你知道的，这也取决于你根据自己对音乐的理解所学到的规则。好的，接下来是我的最爱音乐游戏博物馆的下一站，好吧，接下来是我的最爱音乐游戏博物馆的下一站，我们有一个小节目，一个名为微软“歌唱大师”（Microsoft Songsmith）的电脑程序。你听说过微软“歌唱大师”吗？我没有。我的意思是，听起来隐约有点耳熟，但我从来没用过。没有。
I'm going to let Microsoft Songsmith have the first word here. This is a little Songsmith commercial where they explain how it works. Okay. You're writing music? When did you learn how to write music? You sing into a microphone while the drummer plays along. And then when songsmith makes the music, you're on your way to a song.
我要让微软“歌唱大师”自己先说。这是一个关于“歌唱大师”的小广告，里面解释了它是如何工作的。好的。你在写音乐？你什么时候学会写音乐的？你对着麦克风唱歌，鼓手跟着伴奏。然后“歌唱大师”创作出音乐，你就走上创作歌曲的道路了。
Now SongSmith comes up with a music that matches your voice. You sing into a microphone while the drummer plays along. And then when SongSmith makes the music, you're on your way to a song. You can choose the style, you can set the mood, and the chords will match what you sing, you can change the music as much as you like, so it really is your thing. So basically, you can sing anything that's vaguely melodic into Song Smith and it will generate music around that. Wow, that's something else.
现在“歌唱大师”能创作出与你的声音相匹配的音乐。你对着麦克风唱歌，鼓手跟着伴奏。然后当“歌唱大师”创作出音乐时，你就走上了创作歌曲的道路。你可以选择风格，可以设定情绪，和弦会配合你唱的内容，你可以随心所欲地更改音乐，所以这真的是属于你的作品。所以基本上，你可以把任何隐约有旋律的东西唱给“歌唱大师”听，它就会围绕这个生成音乐。哇，那真是别有一番风味。
And this is from the mid-2000s. Like all the promotional material I find about Song Smith is like, it's a great sketch tool for musicians. And it's like, it feels like they're tool for musicians. And it's like, you know, it's for like, like, it feels like they're trying to market to like serious songwriters. And I mean, you know, to be fair, I think that's like entirely valid.
这是2000年代中期的产物。我找到的所有关于“歌唱大师”的宣传材料都说，它是音乐人的绝佳草图工具。感觉就像它们是音乐人的工具。而且，你知道的，它是为那种，感觉就像它们试图向严肃的词曲作者营销。我的意思是，你知道的，平心而论，我认为这完全合情合理。
Like I think if someone wanted to use it that way, they totally could, you know, because generally people do write music within a certain set of rules and parameters. As much as we want to think that we all do things that are completely unique and like, and stuff, it's like, there's a certain amount of just like, we're within a scale. We're within a certain Western tradition. That does make sense, yeah.
就像我认为如果有人想那样使用它，他们完全可以，你知道的，因为通常人们确实会在一定的规则和参数范围内创作音乐。尽管我们很想认为我们所做的一切都是完全独特且与众不同的，但事实是，在某种程度上，我们都在一个音阶内。我们都在某种西方传统之内。这确实说得通，是的。
But there is something about songs, but we We're like the sound of the instruments and everything it says so silly that it's really like provided a lot of great opportunities for wonderful joke songs and my favorite thing that someone's ever done with Songsmith and actually there are a lot of these on YouTube. You can find videos of people who have taken isolated vocal tracks from hit songs and put them into song Smith. So I'm gonna play one of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song.
但关于“歌唱大师”，有些地方——我们就像乐器的声音以及它所表达的一切，实在是太滑稽了，以至于它确实为许多精彩的搞笑歌曲提供了绝佳的机会。我最喜欢别人用“歌唱大师”做的事情是，实际上YouTube上有很多这样的视频。你可以找到人们从热门歌曲中提取独立的声乐音轨，然后把它们放进“歌唱大师”里。所以我打算放一首这首歌。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。
I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan of the song. I'm a big fan on that song. Very different take. Oh my goodness. That's hilarious.
我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是这首歌的超级粉丝。我是那首歌的超级粉丝。完全不同的演绎。哦天哪。太搞笑了。
What a novel use of that technology. That's a really fun thing to do. Yeah, I think it's genius. It really like, it really feeds my soul. These like, these songsmith covers. I think that like music is the language of the soul. But I think that humor is also like a huge part of the language of the soul And so yeah, I think you know, I I consider this to be valid art personally
这项技术的使用方式真是新颖。做这个真的很有趣。是的，我觉得这太天才了。它真的，怎么说呢，真的滋养了我的灵魂。这些诸如歌曲创作者的翻唱。我觉得音乐是灵魂的语言。但我认为幽默也是灵魂语言中非常巨大的一部分，所以是的，我觉得，你知道的，我个人认为这是真正的艺术。
Totally, I do too, you know like it's just a different form I mean it has its limitations, but it's it's lovely and brings joy and makes you think about the original song and the art of that song even designing the algorithm that creates the song is in art form. And that's so cool. So the next stop on the tour, this also kind of gets into some territory that it's going to, it kind of feels less like a game, but it feels really related to songsmith and to this whole idea of having a set of rules and you know, and generating songs for entertainment out of it. And it's also like another one of my favorite things
完全同意，我也是，你知道的，这只是一种不同的形式。我的意思是它有局限性，但它是可爱能带来快乐的，并让你思考原本的歌曲以及那首歌的艺术性。甚至连设计创作这首歌的算法也是一种艺术形式。这太酷了。所以巡演的下一站，这也开始涉及一些领域，感觉不那么像个游戏，但它真的与歌曲创作者以及拥有规则集并通过其生成用于娱乐的歌曲的整个想法息息相关。这也是我的最爱之一。
ever. So I'm just going to read this, I'm going to read a bit of this how stuff works article like pretty much word for word real quick. So researchers from the University of Toronto trained a recurrent neural network, a type of complex artificial intelligence, to write a song inspired by an image of a Christmas tree. They taught the AI to compose tunes by feeding it 100 hours of online music. They also gave the program thousands of images with captions so that it could link specific words to visual patterns. Then create the lyrics and music when provided a picture. Sanja Fiddler, one of the folks who worked on it, says, instead of buying a karaoke machine with a
有史以来最喜欢的。所以我只是要读这个，我要一字不差地快速阅读这篇“How Stuff Works”文章的一小部分。因此，多伦多大学的研究人员训练了一个循环神经网络（一种复杂的AI），来创作一首受圣诞树图片启发的歌曲。他们通过向其输入100小时的网络音乐，教人工智能作曲。他们还向该程序提供了数千张带标题的图片，以便它可以将特定的单词链接到视觉模式。然后根据提供的图片创建歌词和音乐。参与这项工作的桑娅·菲德勒说，与其买一台带有特定曲目的卡拉OK机，
certain track on it, you can create your own karaoke at home by throwing in some interesting photos and inviting the machine to generate music for you. I think it has endless possibilities. Now I'm going to play you some of the song that this artificial intelligence wrote. Okay, so here's the photo that they fed into the computer. It's a photograph of a Christmas tree. It's lit, has presents around it. It's the bottom half of a Christmas tree, very classically done with red and green and gold ornaments. Very, very fancy. And here's the song. I swear to Christmas Eve, I hope that it's on to 6. That's a little ominous.
你可以在家里通过输入一些有趣的照片，并邀请机器为你生成音乐来创建自己的卡拉OK。我认为它有无限的可能。现在我要给你播放一些这个人工智能创作的歌曲。好的，这是他们输入电脑的照片。这是一张圣诞树的照片。它亮着灯，周围有礼物。这是圣诞树的底部，非常经典的红、金、绿色装饰。非常非常华丽。这就是那首歌。我向圣诞前夜发誓，我希望它在6号。这有点不祥。
I can hear the music coming from the hall. A fairytale. Oh, I can hear the music coming from the hall. A fairytale. Oh, I can hear the music coming from the hall. A fairytale. A rhythmistry. There it is.
我能听到从大厅传来的音乐。一个童话故事。哦，我能听到从大厅传来的音乐。一个童话故事。哦，我能听到从大厅传来的音乐。一个童话故事。一个韵律。就是这样。
A rhythmistry. There it is. A rhythmistry. There it is. A rhythmistry. There it is. There it is. There it is.
一个韵律。就是这样。一个韵律。就是这样。一个韵律。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。
There it is. There it is. There it is. There it is. There it is. There it is. There it is. There it is. Oh, that is amazing, like, eerie and cool and odd. It reminds me of, like, you know, kind of like a kid might write before they have, like, internalized all of these, like, ideas of, like, what is good and bad songwriting, or something like that, which is ironic,
就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。哦，这太棒了，有点诡异、酷炫又怪异。这让我想起，你知道的，就像一个孩子在内化所有这些关于什么是好的和坏的歌曲创作等观念之前可能会写的东西，诸如此类，这很讽刺，
because, like, this is coming from is coming from an AI that has been fed so much conventional music. It just makes me think, I want this AI to stay exactly as it is forever. Whatever iPhone app is going to come from this kind of technology, I feel it's going to be less interesting than if you just take the code as it is and slap it in our hands right now. Let's start giving it pictures. So funny. Okay, so what's your final one? Okay, so the final thing I thought we'd play a little game of our own.
因为，这就像是来自一个被喂了如此多传统音乐的人工智能。这只是让我觉得，我希望这个人工智能永远保持原样。无论什么iPhone应用程序会从这种技术中诞生，我觉得它都不如直接把代码拿来并立刻交到我们手上那么有趣。让我们开始给它照片吧。太搞笑了。好吧，你的最后一个是什么？好吧，我想我们自己可以玩个小游戏。
Oh, cool. That's exciting. Okay. Yeah, so I made a music game for us to play that I composed music for. So basically this is like a this is like a 99 PI song music game. And okay, how does it work? So I've composed six rhythm parts and six like sort of lead instrument piano parts. And we're going to roll dice to determine what order they are played in. Oh, it's so good. Okay. Okay. Do I need two six-sided dice or a word? Two six-sided dice, yeah. Two six-sided dice. Okay, hold on. All right. So first take one of the dice and roll for the tempo.
哦，太酷了。令人兴奋。好的。是的，所以我为我们制作了一个我谱曲的音乐游戏。所以基本上这就像是一个99 PI音乐游戏。好的，它是如何运作的？我创作了六个节奏声部和六个某种主旋律钢琴声部。我们要掷骰子来决定它们播放的顺序。哦，太棒了。好的。好的。我需要两个六面骰子还是一个？两个六面骰子，是的。两个六面骰子。好的，等等。好的。所以首先拿出一个骰子来掷节奏。
Three. Okay, so three is 80, which is in my opinion, the best tempo for this song. So good work, Roman. You're all you're already great at this game. With your two dice, designate one die for rhythm and one for lead. So if you have to roll them in separate places or something, you know, they're very different. Oh, good, good. Okay, one for where that sense I did. The last one was the tempo one. I'll do the tempo one is rhythm and the other one probably. Okay. Okay, the tempo one is four and the leader is a one.
三。好的，所以三代表80，在我看来，这是这首歌的最佳节奏。干得好，罗曼。你在这个游戏上已经很厉害了。用你的两个骰子，指定一个骰子作为节奏，一个作为主旋律。所以如果你必须在不同的地方掷它们之类的，你知道的，它们非常不同。哦，好，好。好的，一个用来决定那个。上一个决定的是节奏。我把决定节奏的当成节奏，另一个大概是。好的。好的，节奏是四，主旋律是一。
four, and the leader is a one. Okay, four and one. We're off to a very dramatic start. Okay, and so now we're gonna do that seven more times. Okay, same order, five and three, five and five and five oh six and six how very conventional Two and four oh six and six again One and two One and two. Four and five.
四，主旋律是一。好的，四和一。我们有了一个非常戏剧性的开局。好的，现在我们要再重复七次。好的，同样的顺序，五和三，五和五，五，哦，六和六，多么传统，二和四，哦，又是一个六和六，一和二，一和二。四和五。
You just wrote a song, Roman. That's so excited. I didn't know I had it in me. Let's see how it sounds. Okay. I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, I'm not a man, Oh, it was so good. That was a false ending. That was my one and two. The one that went down to that. Yeah, that's so funny.
你刚刚写了一首歌，罗曼。太令人兴奋了。我不知道我还有这本事。让我们听听它听起来怎么样。好的。我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，我不是个男人，哦，太棒了。那是个虚假的结尾。那是我的“一和二”。那个降下去的音。是的，太搞笑了。
Oh, it turned out so well. So I rolled this a couple of times with Courtney, my partner yesterday. And we, um, I mean, that's something that I thought was great. Was the false ending? Like that's the kind of stuff mean, that's something that I thought was great was the false ending. Like, that's the kind of stuff I've done that I really like and I think it's like great for a laugh and makes it feel like a game. Oh, I love it. It's so much fun. Thank you for, you know, helping me write a song this afternoon. Thank you for writing a song with me, Roman. Oh, it's my pleasure. I never knew how talented I really was. I always knew how talented I really was. I always knew.
哦，结果太棒了。所以昨天我和我的搭档考特尼一起掷了几次骰子。我们，嗯，我是说，我觉得很棒的一点是什么？是虚假的结尾吗？就像那样的事情，我是说，我觉得很棒的一点是虚假的结尾。就像，那是我做过的那种我真的很喜欢的事情，而且我认为这让人忍俊不禁，也让它感觉像个游戏。哦，我太喜欢了。太有趣了。谢谢你，你知道的，今天下午帮我写了一首歌。谢谢你和我一起写歌，罗曼。哦，这是我的荣幸。我从来不知道自己原来这么有才华。我一直都知道自己有多有才华。我一直都知道。
At the beginning of 2021, 99% of visible is Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstad, Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sean Rihall, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lay, Sophia Klatsker, Chris Marubey, Abby Madon, Christopher Johnson, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K, LWN San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, In Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting.
在2021年初，99% Invisible的成员有凯蒂·明格尔、库尔特·科尔施塔德、德兰妮·霍尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、肖恩·里霍尔、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·莱、索菲娅·克拉茨克、克里斯·马鲁贝、艾比·马顿、克里斯托弗·约翰逊，还有我罗曼·马斯。我们是91.7K、旧金山LWN的项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的Radio Row。我们是PRX旗下Radiotopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最好、最具创新性节目的联盟。
Discover, listen, and support them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show in joint discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram and write it too. We'll be returning to our normal reported stories next week. But if you like these mini stories and you haven't heard them all over the years, I think this is episode 11 at this point. You can find them all at 99PI.org. Radio til the end. From PRX.
请在 radiotopia.fm 上发现、收听并支持他们所有人。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars 或@节目 @99PI org，或者在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。我们下周将回归正常的报道故事。但如果你喜欢这些迷你故事，并且这些年里没有听完全部，我想这是目前的第11集。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到所有这些。电台直到永远。来自 PRX。
Radio Tepia from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。